Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Folge der Podcast UFO Hype Trump. Hallo. Sorry, so. Hallo, das Podcast UFO. Letztes Mal waren wir in diesem halligen Raum, heute sind wir ganz weit draußen, heute sind wir live von der Arktis. Klimawandel, wir brauchen dich, wir beschwören dich. Mach mal irgendwas, dass der Klimawandel schneller kommt, fahre mit dem Auto ein paar Mal hier um den Block. Wir essen Fleisch. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast Uferinchen. In einer kleinen Ausgabe heute mal. Ich habe an Tag 18 bereits unseren Hund, den führenden Schlittenhund, gegessen, weil es so kalt war. Wir hatten keine Nahrungsvorräte mehr. Tag 19. Beate hat die Hütte verlassen, um nach Hilfe zu suchen. Nur noch Stefan und ich sind jetzt hier. Seit zehn Tagen hängen wir aufeinander rum. Tag dreihundzwanzig. Beate ist noch immer nicht zurückgekehrt. Dafür eine andere Inuit-Dame. Tag achtundzwanzig. Die … Wir wissen nicht, welche Sprache die Inuit-Dame spricht, deswegen haben wir sie mit Inuit Inuit angesprochen. Aber sie hat fünfzig Wörter für ... Fickt euch! Ich dachte, meine Blicke haben Sie ihm verraten, er hat es nicht geglaubt. Ach ja, und ich hatte mein erstes Mal. Mit der Inuit-Dame. Ich glaube, das ist, habe ich schon mal gesagt, glaube ich. Welche Geräusche kannst du gut imitieren? Ich glaube, was ich am besten imitieren kann, ist schwere Stiefel stapfen durch hohen Schnee. Und zwar, okay, oder Krümelmonster ist. Das ist auch der Seine beieinander, ich glaube., und jetzt ein Schlag ins Gesicht. Krümelmonster stapft mit grossen Stiefeln, essend durch den Schnee. Und wird dabei geschlagen. Nee, es ist eher so ein... Das ist, glaube ich, der beste Job, den man hat, in so Comicbüchern, die Soundeffekte verwörtlichen. Kravem, Krapatz, Rapapau, Ringedink, auch der erste der mit Vroom, weil es ist nicht Broom, Broom, es ist dieser Lkw angefangen, ist Broom, aber dieses Vroom, das ist noch was anderes, was Spitzes und supermännisch lupfen. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen wie dein Big Tasty Onkel, wo man sagen kann, mein Grossvater hat damals das Peng erfunden.
Schüsse klingt doch gar nicht wie Peng. Ne, genau wie Hunde klingt auch nicht wie Wauwau und Katzen klingen auch remotely wie Wauwau. Es ist eher so ein Wa-Weh-Web. Es hätte auch Webb sein können.
Webb ist eigentlich relativ nah dran an dem Hund. Web ist näher dran als Wao. Mach mal Wao. Und damit herzlich willkommen zu dem Podcast, der berühmt geworden ist durch seine knallharten, effektiven On-the-Nose-Soundeffekte. Ich hoffe, weil ihr diesen Podcast gerade mit Katzen hört, haben die sich hoffentlich gerade nicht gerade in voller Schreck und Angst vor dem Hunde. Hunde. Heute sagt niemand mehr Hund. Heute sagt man vor dem Hunde. Heute haben sie sich vielleicht vor dem Hunde hinter der Türe versteckt, an diesem schönen Freitag. Das war immer so, wenn man an so einem, der Schulweg, man geht nach Hause, stapft durch den hohenen Schnee und man sieht dann so ein Schild an so einem Haus, Vorsicht vor dem Hunde und man denkt sich, du meinst Hund, vor dem Hund? Nee, Vorsicht vor dem Hunde. Warum Hunde? Der Hunde hinter der Türe. Moment mal, wie viel Uhr ist es gerade? Neune. Was ist los mit Ihnen? Ich bin dafür, dass alle Wörter auf E enden. Warum? Und dann, ja, das können Sie bei meinem Seminar, warum alle Wörter auf E enden sollten, Hörne. Wie heißen Sie denn? Erich. Jeder Gag endet mit einem, ja, na gut, so musste es ja jetzt erscheinen.
Naja, so musste der Enden, der Sketch. Das weiß ich noch genau, wie ich zu meiner Lehrerin damals gegangen bin und ich wollte das Wort Umhang schreiben und ich habe sie gefragt, entschuldigen Sie, Frau Bruckner, wie schreibt man denn Entschuldigung, wie bitte, wie schreibt man Und eigentlich hast du einen schweren Herzinf in Frage. Aber niemand konnte helfen. Einfach komplett direkt in die Inklusionsklasse gekommen. Straight Umhang. Wie dick musst du sein, um in die Inklusionsklasse zu kommen? Ich war ja im Inklusionskindergarten. Ich weiss, wie du schon erzählt hast. Doch, ich war tatsächlich in einem Inklusionskindergarten, wo auch ganz viele Kinder mit Rollstühlen waren. Für mich als Kind dachte ich, Alter, ich will auch einen Rollstuhl haben. Wie geil ist das denn? Nicht mehr gehen. Hallo, die rollen durch die Gegend. Und mir hat es auch immer Spaß gemacht, die einander rumzuschieben und rumzurollen. Und so als Kind, du raffst es ja auch nicht. Ich hätte zwei Leute genommen, dem einen eine Lanze in die Hand gedrückt, dem anderen auch eine Lanze. Und dann hätte ich so ein Teoste gemacht auf dem Hofe, würde ich die einfach
ineinander laufen lassen und dann gucken wir,
wer gewinnt. Oder zum Beispiel, ich hatte immer einen Freund
in meinem Freundeskreis, also einen Kindergartenfreund,
mit dem war ich im Kindergarten befreundet und dann
in der Schulzeit hat man sich auch noch getroffen
und der war auf einer Montessori-Schule
als einziger, wir waren alle auf normalen
Schulen. Ich war auf einer Montezuma-Schule.
Und der konnte
nicht lesen. Der Montessori-Schule konnte nicht lesen, als wir schon lesen konnten. Damals war das Spiel Pokémon wahnsinnig in, wo man viel lesen musste. Und dann haben wir das immer gespielt und er so, ja, ich kann nicht lesen. Und man ist ja als Kind geneigt, einerseits man hat eine grausame Ader zu sagen, du kannst nicht lesen, du bist ein Arschloch, auf der anderen Seite hat der gesagt, Moment mal, Freunde, pass mal auf, die Erfinderin der Montessori-Schule, der Montessori-Pädagogik ist auf dem, lass mich raten, 10.000 Liraschein abgebildet und wir so, wow, wow, okay, du bist ein krasser Typ, du bist ein krasser Kerl, so das war wichtig als Kind, dass der Erfinderin der Art von Schule, auf die man geht, auf dem Zehntausend-Lire-Schein abgewinkelt ist.
Weißt du, wo ich war? Ich war auf der Südschule. Das ist eine fucking Himmelsrichtung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob da irgendwas anderes mithalten kann.
Gibt es nicht irgendeinen Autoren, Leute, Heinrich Böll, Hermann Hesse, Heinrich Gersel, irgendjemanden. Gibt es nicht noch einen?
Nein, wir nehmen eine Himmelsrichtung. Und danach kommen Urzeiten. Tage, die Donnerstagsschule, die Montagsschule, die Mondschule, die Saturnschule. Ernsthaft, Leute, es gibt doch auch moderne, vielleicht mal weibliche Literatoren. Vielleicht kann man da nicht was machen, da gibt's doch tolle junge Leute im Independent-Bereich. Nein, das ist die Maiskolbenschule! Wann glaubst du, kommt zum ersten Mal so die Mariah Carey-Schule? Also sowas, wo man in der Popkultur ankommt. Weil ich mein, also man will natürlich immer die Weltliteratur nehmen. Oh, oh, oh, Böll, Günther Gras, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,renmatt, oh! Weißt du was, mal ein bisschen hier, die Michael-Jackson-Schule. Ja. Oder die Mariah Carey. Die Mighty Ducks, die Adidas-Schule. Das wird doch kommen. Oh, das wird in unserer kapitalistisch geprägten Zukunft, wird das doch eh kommen. Alter, ich merke die ganze Zeit, in dir steckt ein wahr, also du bist der grösste Kapitalismuskritiker. Du abonnierst dazu gerade. Du, ich bin halt nicht so ein Fan von Unterdrückung der Arbeiterklasse, sorry, sorry! Ja gut, jetzt ist so ein linksversiffter Podcast, wie das auch mittlerweile hier, weil du deine Lehren durchdrückst, deine scheiss-maxistischen Kack-Thesen. Und mal ganz im Ernst, wir haben heute zusammen den Wahl-O-Mat gemacht. Ich hab die Partei, mit Abstand war vorne, danach grün, dann linke, und du aber auch nur mit so 56 Prozent. Die NPD hatte 46 Prozent. Also da ist schon viel im Argen bei mir offensichtlich. Aber du hattest mit 86 Prozent tatsächlich die Linken. Klar. Heißt, du bist, und danach kam auch sofort diese super linksextreme Partei. Heißt, du bist echt am Ende. Du, die kommunistische Weltrevolution steht mit v. Ich will auch nicht, dass deine scheiß Sozi-Wellen hier dem im Podcast beigetreten werden.
Das ist auch...
Nachher wird das hier so ein... wie so ein verbotenes Jugend... so ein Campus-Sender,
den man...
Das ist der Verfassungsschutz.
Genau.
Achtet auf uns.
Der ist ja auf dem linken Auge blind. Und auf dem rechten auch. Der hat nur noch die
Nase. Der Verfassungsschutz hat nur noch die Nase, Leute. Er riecht nur noch. Er ist blind. Obacht, er schmeckt nur noch und riecht, fühlt ein bisschen. Ohne Fühlen der beschissenste Sinn, sind wir uns einig? Nee. Nee? Du fühlst gerne? Ja, es gibt eine bestimmte Situation, wo man gerne fühlt, oder nicht? Bisschen kalt, findest du, oder nicht? Ja, oder? Bestimmt, du hast recht. Winter steht schon wieder auf der Haustür, ne? Atomwinter, habe ich gehört. Wir sitzen ja gerade in so einem kleinen Iglu hier, den wir uns gebaut haben in der Arktis. Wie funktioniert das genau? Also du, wie ich es verstanden habe, musst du in die tiefe Eisschichten vordringen, musst dann mit so einer Säge so kleine Würfel ausschneiden und die stapelst du übereinander, bis sie eine Kuppel ergeben. Was ich weiss, ist, dass der Boden des Iglus muss höher liegen als der Eingang des Iglus, damit sie... Und wie kommst du dann rein? Ich glaube, daran haben die nicht gedacht. Wie kommst du dann rein? Du schlüpfst halt unten durch. Du gehst halt erst die Treppen runter, dann gehst du den Eingang, dann klärst du die Leiter hoch und dann bist du in deinem Iglu. Da ist ja so ein Code-Eingangseingang-Abeding, da musst du dann 5553 eingeben, dann kürzt du den Fingerabdruckscanner, Iris-Scan und dann kannst du rein. Und dann weil, damit du heizt ja die Luft auf im Iglu und damit die warme Luft nicht rausgeht, weil warme Luft geht ja nach oben, muss es nach oben sehen. So und deswegen so funktioniert ein Iglu. Früher tatsächlich bei meiner Oma gab es wahnsinnig viel Schnee und da war so eine Strasse, weil die relativ südlich in den Nähe der Alpen wohnt. Und da war so eine Strasse, so ein Hang runter und dann war ihr Haus und dann hat der Schneepflug einfach mal so den gesamten Schnee von der ganzen Strasse genommen und einfach runtergeschoben und dann war kurz vor dem Haus meiner Oma ein riesiger Schneeberg. Was ein Bitch-Move. Ein riesiger Schneeberg. Was ein Dusseleger-Move. Es war einerseits durchsicht für uns Kinder natürlich unfassbar geil, so einen riesengrossen Schneeberg zu haben, wo man halt drauf rum und dann konnte man auch so Tunnel graben. Und da haben wir auch mal einen Iglu gebaut und der war fast eingestürzt. Das war tatsächlich, das war ein bisschen klaustrophobisch, weil du bist ja faul, du gräbst ja nur so viel, wie du brauchst und dann steckst du da in so einem Höhlensystem drin und kommst nicht mehr raus. Als Kind wird man ja sehr kreativ. Also ich würde auch Kindern eine grössere Kreativität als die meisten in der Werkstatt unterstellen. Potzblitz! Potzblitz, das ist eine These. Und dann macht man als Kind ja auch aus den meisten Situationen, wenn man irgendwie mal so eine Pütze hat oder so wird da raus dann irgendwie ein Ozean und man spielt Riesen, die gegeneinander in diesem Ozean kämpfen oder keine Ahnung, man spielt mit Schiffen da drin. Denn ich fand es als Kind immer sehren, wenn man so eine Pfütze hat, so wird da raus, dann irgendwie ein Ozean und man spielt Riesen, die Gegner in diesem Ozean kämpfen oder man spielt mit Schiffen da drin. Ich fand es als Kind immer sehr schwierig, wenn dann mal so ein Riesenberg kam aus Schnee, dann was macht man dann damit? Weil du bist in gewisser Weise reizüberflutet. Was spielen wir jetzt damit? Meistens steht man dann davor und denkt, ah, zu cool und geht dann wieder, um dann mit seiner scheiß Pfütze zu spielen. Oder wenn du halt irgendwie die Pistole in der Schublade von deinem Onkel findest, du kannst nicht mit einer Pistole Pistole spielen. Hey, das ist zu crazy. Du kannst mit einem Ast kannst du Gewehr spielen. Genau. Aber wenn du dann wirklich eine MG findest, dann kannst du, was willst du denn machen? Was ist das dann? Ja. Das ist zu real, das funktioniert nicht mehr. Das ist wirklich zu real. Dann geht die Imagination auch ein bisschen flöten. Ist das die Verdammnis des Erwachsenen, dass man immer mehr die tatsächlichen Dinge benutzt und dadurch die Fantasie flöten geht? Ja, es geht viel flöten, das ist glaube ich ein Grundproblem, dass Erwachsen werden. In meinem Buch nachzulesen, alles geht flöten. Und in dem Buch liegt bei eine ... Bach runter. Die Welt ist ja für die Erwachsenen geschaffen, alles was wir um uns sehen ist ja für Erwachsenen gebaut. Ja, außer die Kinderspielplätze, die rutschen, die schaukeln. Naja, aber ich würde sagen, die Kinder sind in dieser Welt fremd. Oh, diese Linksversiffen-Scheiß-Thesen. Die ganzen marxistischen Floskeln hier wieder. Und Grunderwerbsteuer für alle. Nee, ich glaube, das ist der politischste Tag meines Lebens, ich habe auch keine Ahnung. Aber du, ich habe dich beobachtet, ich habe den Wahl-O-Mat entdeckt heute, habe den gemacht, habe der Redaktion gesagt, Leute, der Wahl-O-Mat ist draußen, Achtung, ich habe so eine Klingel, die große Wahl-O-Mat-Klingel. Ich kann ihn nicht ernst nehmen, Wahl-O-Mat, das klingt wie so ein unbegabter Roboter. Und dann, ja damit Leute wie du das auch mal machen, sondern habe ich dich beobachtet, dann habe ich dir gesagt, du kannst den Wahl-O-Mat machen, du warst ganz aufgeregt, hast den dann gemacht. Ich habe mich mal so hinter dich geschmiegt und geguckt, wie du das so machst. Und mir ist aufgefallen, dass wir exakt die gleichen politischen Ansichten haben, ohne dass wir uns jemals groß über Politik ausgetauscht haben. Und ich bin froh, jetzt mal hier in der Antarktis mit dir da was zu sprechen zu können. Jetzt, wo es zählt, jetzt können wir eine neue Gesellschaft aufbauen können, gilt es so. Was machen wir mit diesem Inuit-Volk, was wir unterdrückt haben die ganze Zeit? Was bauen wir daraus? Machen wir eher, bauen wir eine Demokratie, bauen wir eine Aristokratie, bauen wir eine Elitegesellschaft? Oligarchie, da weiß niemand so genau, was das sein soll. Mindestens einer von uns muss Olli heißen, sonst läuft da gar nichts. Was machen wir jetzt mit diesen Leuten? Und ich habe dich beobachtet, wir haben exakt die gleichen Ansichten, ausser wenn es ums Geld geht, weil ich will mein Geld behalten, ich will reicher werden, dir ist Geld scheiss egal. Schön Geld den Armen und Kranken, das ist so meine Einschätzung. Genau, Armen und Kranke, alle sollen Geld haben, das ist sozi-scheiße halt einfach. Und da bin ich einfach der Knallall der Kapitalist und denke mir, ich will Geld, ich, ich, ich, ich will Geld. Ich versteh das schon. Darum geht's mir primär. Alles andere ist mir so ein bisschen egal. Und da ging es dann so ein bisschen auseinander. Wir hatten tatsächlich auch heute eine semipolitische Auseinandersetzung über das Tempolimit auf Autobahnen. Ja, das stimmt. Damals angeschrien. Bleifuss Stefan natürlich wieder überhaupt keinen Finger breit von seiner scheiß konservativen, alte, weisse Männerposition abkommt. das ich will schön hier ballern, Fussball, Autobahn, Frauen, Sex. Ich will wirklich zum Fussball, zu meinem Vibe, da hat das Essen am Tisch zu stehen, deswegen bretter ich mit meinem Mercedes mit 200 Karacho über die scheiss Bahn. So, und solche scheiss Parolen hat Stefan um sich geworden. Also ich muss sagen, das Tempolimit ist das Beste, was mir passieren konnte als Mensch. Ich fahre ganz oft von Dortmund nach Köln. Das ist jedes Wochenende zweimal, zurück und hin, meistens. Und das ist wirklich einfach das Coolste der Welt, dass es Tempolimit gibt. Es kam heute dann raus, als Hauptgrund dagegen war, Staus bildeten sich häufiger wohl. Das ist empirisch belegt, diese empirische Untersuchung würde ich gerne mal sehen, aber das ist ein Seitenhieb nur am Rande. Und dann, das kommt dann immer als Ausrede und ich behaupte aber, du kannst, weil du kannst ohne Tempo-Limit, kannst du einfach selber dein Tempo bestimmen. Du kannst selber entscheiden, wie schnell ich irgendwo da sein will. Die meisten sagen sich, nö, ich fahre einfach mit 80 irgendwo auf irgendeiner Spur, ist mir scheißegal. Und dann komme ich mit meinem weißen Flitzer und flitze durch. Weißt du, das ist mir scheißegal. Und du musst, ich bin kurz davor, meinen Führerschein zu verlegen, muss ich dazu sagen, ich habe jetzt zwei Punkte. Oh ja, das stimmt. Und habe jetzt ein riesen Knöllchen bekommen und das alles geht so ein bisschen den Bach unter meiner Autofahrkarriere. Aber ich halte mich da nicht an Regeln. Ich bin ein Rebell, auf der Strasse bin ich ein anderer Mensch. Ich sag ganz eindeutig, der Mensch ist der Maschine unterlegen. Und wenn der Mensch ohne Regeln mit Maschinen hantiert, gibt es Tote. Der Mensch kann doch nicht so einen fucking acht Zylinder Supermotor kontrollieren, mit dem er irgendwie mit 400 km h über die Autobahn ballern kann. Und es ist ja auch überhaupt nicht zukunftsweisend. Die Autos werden immer schneller, immer schneller und der Mensch wird immer langsamer und dummer und hat immer mehr Handys in der Hand. Und das geht nicht. Da sterben Leute. Und da sterben ja die Schnellen. Und du willst auch gerade die Schnellen, dass die nicht sterben. Die musst du doch bewahren. Das soll eine schnelle Gesellschaft sein. Ich bin der Meinung auch, dass du auf den deutschen Autobahnen kannst du Leute outsmarten. Du kannst schneller am Ziel sein als dumme Menschen. Einfach, ich hab mittlerweile diese Strecke, kenne ich so gut, dass ich einfach an manchen Stellen anders fahre als die meisten anderen. Ich weiß, wo Spuren zusammengeführt werden, weil ich die Verkehrszeichen mal beachte. Man kann relativ gut antizipieren, wo es schneller geht. Natürlich gehe ich dann auf diese Spur, wo nicht die beiden Spuren zusammengeführt werden. Und dann bist du einfach schneller. Allein so etwas wie an Reizverschluss halten oder so. Und ganz bis zum Ende der Spur fahren rechts. Das spart so viel Zeit. Du musst einfach mal... Also Arschloch sein, meinst du? Ja, richtiges Arschloch sein. Schön mit links blinken und die Hand an der Hupe. Das bin ich. Die Hand am links blinken und an der Hupe. Auf der anderen Seite, ich finde, wenn es eine Höchstgrenze für Geschwindigkeiten auf der deutschen Autobahn geben sollte, sollte es auch eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit in der deutschen Fussgeneration geben. Da gibt es Leute, die wetzen, die rennen, die sprinnen. Ja, weil du flanierst. Das kann so nicht sein. Ich flanier, ich bummel, ich bummel. Nee, du bummelst und manchmal flanierst du, meistens bummelst du, mit deinen grossen Einkaufstaschen von Primark und so. Seht ihr ja immer in Köln rumlaufen, mit so grossen, so Gruppen Norma und den ganzen Depots, du bist so ein Depot-Einkäufer. War nicht in Spanien der Anschlag, der Terroranschlag auf die Flaniermeile? Noch nie wurde das Wort Flaniermeile so oft im Fernsehen genannt. Flanier. Die sind da flaniert, er ist gesaust und das kann ja nicht gut gehen. Wir wissen doch alle, da kommt es zu großen Kravems. Sausen plus Flanieren ist gleich Kapon. Ich meine, das war ein internationaler, terroristischer, islamistischer Angriff auf das Flanieren. Ja. Und nicht nur, dass sie keinen Bock haben, dass wir Menschen nicht haben. Aber ich lass mir mein Flanieren nicht wegnehmen. Nein, der deutsche Flaniertag, Flanieren bis die Füsse bluten, sag ich, Leute. Flanieren ohne Blanieren. Flanieren ohne Blamieren. Und dann gehst du da immer mit deinen grossen Taschen, und dann langsam quetschst du dich durch die Fußgängerzone. Flanieren geht überstudieren. Und dann sausen Leute an dir vorbei, und du kommst damit halt nicht klar. Deswegen willst du jetzt das Tempolimit da. Ich bin Flaneur, weißt du, hier ist eine linksversiffte Scheiße, die ich mir nicht ertragen kann. Warum gibt es keine Rechtsversifte? Glaubst du, wir sind denn der politikloseste Podcast? Glaubst du, wir tragen dazu bei, zur Politikverdrossenheit mit unserem kleinen Spaßprojekt? Nein, nein, nein, Verdrossenheit ist nicht dasselbe Ignoranz. Wir sind Politik ignorant. Wir kennen uns mega gut aus, lesen alle Zeitungen, sind super informiert. Wir ignorieren uns nur bewusst, weil wir es nicht mögen, weil es keinen Spaß macht, weil wir sind Spassmenschen, wir sagen, wir wollen Spaß haben.
Ich glaube, wir sind zu zynisch und das ist nicht gut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, sind wir so zynisch?
Ja, ich bin zynisch.
Ja, stimmt dir ist echt alles scheißegal.
Ich denke mir, die meisten Menschen sind mir egal, die meisten Politikentscheidungen sind mir egal, ich schalte ein, wenn es spannend wird.
Ja, aber wenn ein Fisch stirbt, dann irgendwie erstmal in der Woche Urlaub. Beim Brenntpunkt, beim Brennpunkt bis zu eine Woche Urlaub. Ja, mein Fisch ist gestorben. Ich schalte ein, wenn ein Brennpunkt ist. Und dann aber auch mit so einer Popcorn-Schüssel. Das ist der Höhepunkt einer menschlichen Interaktion, ist Brennpunkt. Erst wenn es brennt, dann interessiert es dich für Menschen. Ja, aber dann weine ich auch direkt. Da bin ich sehr überemotional. Ich bin bei Filmen sehr emotional, bei der Realität gar nicht. Ich habe am Wochenende E.T. gesehen, zum ersten Mal. Und ich habe, also ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt, aber der hat mich so mitgenommen, der Film. Und ich habe bestimmt 20, 30 Prozent des Films geweint. Ich bin da, mich hat das so mitgenommen, das meine ich jetzt, das meine ich, wir labern oft Quatsch und wir machen oft Scherze und man kann uns oft nicht glauben, wenn wir Dinge sagen, aber ich habe wirklich bestimmt 40 bis 60 Prozent des Films habe ich geweint, weil ich das so traurig fand und so schön, es ist so ein schöner Film, weißt du, und dann da bin ich plötzlich emotional, aber was dann die SPD vorschlägt und ob hier die kleine Clara von diesen ganzen SOS-Kinderdörfern-Post, die ich immer bekomme. Aber da kam noch jetzt dieses Video von dem Casting von dem kleinen Jungen raus, wo Steven Svillak den Typ castet und der halt instant irgendwie anfängt zu weinen und irgendwie super gelivert, einfach auch improvisiert, glaube ich. Der spielt die Szene, wo sie ihm den E.T. wegnehmen wollen. Genau. Und dann kommt halt so ein Polizeiofficer und sagt ihm halt, wir müssen das nehmen, sie haben noch einen Alien im Haus. Ja, wir müssen das jetzt wirklich mitnehmen. Tipp, sag einfach nicht ja, dann würden die vielleicht einfach gehen. Und dann muss er halt diese Szene spielen und das ist ein Audition-Tape quasi. Das ist super gut. Und der so richtig gut. Und dann hat er später wohl im Interview gesagt, dass er das gemacht hat, weil er an seinen Hund gedacht hat, der gestorben ist. Und der ist einfach so drin, ich unterstelle ihm auch so eine Art von Behinderung, dass er sich das so gut vorstellen kann einfach, weiß ich nicht. Aber der ist unfassbar begabt da drin, sich das vorzustellen, in Emotionen reinzuversetzen. Der ist einfach in diesem jungen Alter unfassbar gut. Aber aus dem ist dann auch, ich glaube, so Kinderstar ist das schlimmste Schicksal, was ein Mensch haben kann. Ja, schau dich an. Das mit Abstand schlimmste Schicksal. Nicht so schlimmer als Kinderstar sein. Du schaust zurück auf deine Jugend, du schaust zurück auf dieses Demotape, das wird jetzt geschehen, viraler Hit. Ja, toll, vor zehn Jahren konnte ich mir gut schauspielen, jetzt arbeite ich bei KFC irgendwie, kratze ich das Fett aus den Ritzen. Das Lustigste aller Zeiten ist eine leichtere Insta-Story aus dem Lego-Magazin, aber Photoshop-Philipp ist die lustigste Parallele, weil er ist nicht mehr ganz so jung gewesen, als er Photoshop-Philipp wurde, aber er war ja auch in so einem gewissen Kreis so ein kleiner Star, so ein kleiner Kinderstar, kleiner Rebell und dann hat man so nach und nach immer mal mitbekommen, was aus dem geworden ist und so und ein Jahr nach seinem Erfolg hat er die Schule abgebrochen, erste Klasse wiederholt und dann irgendwann hat er die Schule abgebrochen, mittlerweile macht er irgendwo eine Ausbildung, mittlerweile hat er die auch abgebrochen und seine Haare werden immer längerärzer. Er hat auch noch eine Zeit lang Poetry Slam gemacht, wo ich mir dachte, so Alter, wann muss man eingreifen? Und dann haben wir noch auf so einer Weihnachtsfeier oder so, stand er plötzlich mit so langen Haaren und so Kifferaugenring und so einer Zigarette im Mund neben uns, war so far out, viel cooler als wir. So einen beschriebenen Zettel in einer zittrigen Hand, so als wollte er gleich anfangen zu slammen, einfach so, schautaut immer so auf so einen Zettel, wo du denkst, gleich geht's los. Das weiss man bei Poacheslammern immer nicht. Die sind ja mitten im Gespräch, fangen die plötzlich an zu slammen. Das weiss man ja nicht. Und ich rede mit dir, aber rede ich wirklich mit dir? Oder rede ich nur über mich? Ich wollte nur ein bisschen mit seiner Freundin gehen. Bist du auch mit ihr zusammen, oder? Wir sind noch zusammen, zusammen sammeln. Man sammelt in einer Beziehung nur Gedanken von anderen. Das hast du dir aufgeschrieben. Ne, das, äh, ja, ich habe, ich dachte mir schon, dass du mich ansprichst darauf, ob wir noch zusammen sind.
Mach's gut, tschüss, viel Spaß in der Zukunft.
Aber Kinder, halt die, und Kinderstar ist echt, weil du, das ist ja eigentlich dem, dem, dem Grund menschlichen Bedürfnis nach Perfektion genau gegenübergesetzt.
Der, der Mensch schaut in die Zukunft und denkt sich, oh geil, irgendwann mal bin ich total, von mir aus auch nur, ich bin ein guter Vater, ich bin ein guter Mensch, ich bin ein guter Schauspieler, ich bin ein guter Musiker, Künstler, was auch immer. Aber wenn du in die Vergangenheit guckst und du siehst dieses viral gehende Tape von dir und du denkst dir, jetzt bin ich schlechter, wie schaust du denn in die Zukunft? Du denkst dir, jetzt geht es nur noch bergab. Du hast keine Ziele mehr, es kann nur noch bergab gehen.
Der schlimmste, der tragischste, wirklich der schlimmste Schicksal für mich der ganzen aller Welt ist Lance Armstrong, Louis Armstrong, nee, Ace, wie heisst er, Jeff Armstrong, wahrscheinlich heisst er Ace. Ace Armstrong, Arm Armstrong.
Leg Armstrong.
Neil Armstrong.
Auf dem Mond, wo es als...
Warney!
Der denkt sich auch so, dein ganzes Leben, er trainiert jeden Tag, sprintet, wir waren auf dem Mond, er ist zurück, Blumen, alles so, okay, nächste Woche Saturn.
Nein, Neil, das war es jetzt erst mal. Oder Angelique Kerber, um mal ein popkulturelles Beispiel aus der Tenniswelt zu nehmen, wo ich weiß, dass du zu Hause bist, die hat ja jetzt von einem Jahr ... hat sie Wimbledon gewonnen. Winston. Hat sie Wimbledon gewonnen, was ja so der krasseste Erfolg war. Und die ist einfach unfassbar jung. Weltranglisten eins, weil du glamourst und dann so Grand Slam Punkte, kriegst so viel, dass die auf Platz eins der Weltrangliste ist. So seit Jahren war wieder eine Deutsche auf der Weltrangliste, dann auf Platz eins, unfassbar jung noch, ja, und das war's. Aber am Anfang der Karriere hat sie die Venus oder Serena Williams geschlagen und hat die weltbeste Tennisspielerin geschlagen,
so ohne Zweifel, und das war dann einfach, dann hat die auch alles erreicht. Und jetzt, heute, nee, gestern ist sie rausgeflogen bei den US Open, ein Jahr danach, jetzt ist es mittlerweile läuft gar nichts mehr. Das ist auch krass. Was ist denn Ansporn, wenn du alles erreicht hast? Deswegen ist dieses Weltrangliste auch so uncool, weil du weisst, dass du der Beste bist. naja, das stimmt vor allem ist es es verändert sich ja auch nichts. Ich meine, wenn du einen Film machst, dann heißt der Film ist auf Platz Nummer eins der Einspielergebnisse, dann kommt der nächste Film und dann ist so, ich will wieder Nummer eins werden. Nee, das ist doch egal. Aber wenn du selber der Menschheit... Bei sowas sind die Einspielergebnisse doch scheißegal. Wenn du so ein Kunstwerk machst, sind die Einspieler doch scheißegal. Ja gut, ist ja die Frage, wie du an den Film rangehst. Aber ich glaube, so ein Christopher Nolan, glaube ich, der schaut schon auch aufs Box Office. Ja, das kann mir auch vorstellen. So, der ist ein cooler Typ vielleicht und macht ganz okaye Filme so, dafür, dass es so krass Mainstream ist. Aber ich glaube, das... Worauf... weil ich meine, das sind ja Leute, die kriegen auch keine Kritik mehr. So ein Christopher Nolan, klar in der Öffentlichkeit und so, aber ich glaube, so in dem privaten Kreis und so, die haben ja dann lauter Ja-Sager um sich. Und die können dann eigentlich nur noch... Außer den unsympathischen Bruder. Nee, nee, fand ich so ein Kreisel. Das ist so Christopher Nolan zuhause, ja. Nee, also der Film hat mir dieses Jahr nicht gefallen, den du gemacht hast. Nee, mach mal was mit Western. Stochert in seiner Weihnachts ganz beschämte Stimmung. Christopher, mach doch mal was mit Western. Das war früher immer so toll. Leonardo DiCaprio fand ich ja nicht so gut. Ich finde ja Ralph Fiennes immer viel sympathischer. Ja, sorry. Und mach mal irgendwas mit mehr Pistolen. Das ist immer so toll gewesen früher. Der Bud Spencer mit den Fäusten. Das waren gute Filme. Da war nicht diese ganze Actionkacke. Die hatten Humor und Herz. Und die hatten keine Computer wie du immer da mit deinem Gerätchen. Kreisel, bitte, Christopher, Kreisel! Das ist doch Kinderkram! Ja, sorry, Mama. Die Kartoffelpüree wird so ganz weit ausgebreitet auf dem Teller. Ja, tut mir nein. Es war wirklich ungeschnitten Weihnachten bei mir vor drei Jahren, glaube ich. Hör mal, vor der Bescherung, alle sitzen da, die ganzen Verwandten sitzen da,
mit ihren Weihnachtspullis an und ihren lustigen Elchhüten auf
und mit ihren Geschenken in der Hand und dem Hintergrund war ich Olu Fröhliche.
Und mein Onkel dreht sich zu mir und sagt, haben wir diese Sendung da,
für die du geschrieben hast, Neo Magazin, find ich furchtbar.
Olu Fröhliche, oh du selige Gnaden. Das war echt einfach. Ein bisschen unsympathisch, dieser Jan Böhman. Ja, ein bisschen organfindig. Scheiße, ey. Verwandte sind knallhart und deswegen lieben wir sie. Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres als ungefragte Kritik. Wenn niemand nach deiner Meinung fragt und jemand sagt so, ich weiss nicht, ich schaue ja nicht mehr so viel Fernsehen, das interessiert mich nicht so. Ja, ich liebe diese unbedrängten Beleidigung, wo man nicht das Gefühl hatte, okay, wir reden gerade über meine Nase und gut, die ist halt ein bisschen Ghost, kommt dann im Gespräch raus, aber das Unbedrängte, dieses, deine Nase gefällt mir nicht und dann geht man. Das ist immer das so, wenn Leute reden, als müssen sie jetzt was äussern, aber sie müssen es eigentlich nicht so. Das ist oft so, wenn ich ab und zu mal irgendwie so ein Foto mache mit jemandem oder dann kommt es mir vor, dass jemand sagt so, ah, ein Freund von mir ist total großer Fan von dir, kann ich kurz ein Foto machen für ihn? Ich finde es ja, ich schaue ja irgendwie lieber dann Almost Daily mit Eddie oder so. Okay, sorry, tut mir leid, aber gerne, gerne gebe ich dir ein Foto, einfach so niemand fragt danach. Das ist ja ohnehin das Lustigste, wir sind ja Podcaster und wir schneiden ja auch Podcasts ab und zu und man kann ja durch Schnitt alles ändern. Man kann jemanden so fucking unsympathisch dastehen lassen und ich finde, man hat ja verschiedene Tricks in seiner Scherenkiste, wo man verschiedene Nadeln und verschiedene... Wir sind wie so ein Friseur, kann man sich vorstellen. Genau, ja. Hier ist die Frage, wo wir den Rasierer anlässt. Da ein bisschen schummeln. Und das Beste, was man machen kann, ist, wenn man im Gespräch jemandem eine Frage stellt und dann antwortet die Person und in der Episode schneidet man die Frage raus. So dass es so klingt, als würde so, wenn du zum Beispiel so eine These aufstellen. Was würdest du sagen, war dein stolzester Moment in deinem ganzen Leben, Stefan? Es war dieses eine Mal, als ich einmal da bin bin ich plötzlich auf die Bühne kommen, und wurde einfach so aufgerufen ans Publikum, und ich hab sofort was Lustiges gesagt, und es war einfach richtig cool, weil ich sofort on point da war, und alle haben gelacht, und es war richtig grossartig. Und wenn du jetzt die Frage rausgeschnitten hättest, wär das der unsympathische Moment gewesen. Ja, du, Fragen raus, oder einfach, du kannst auch Leute mal ins Wort fallen lassen. Das mache ich manchmal bei diesem Podcast, dass wenn ich mich verhasble oder so, so tue, als ob du eher reingrätscht. Und was dann immer so klingt, als würdest du mich unterbrechen und deswegen würde ich aufgeben zu sprechen. Ach, das ist ja nicht schlecht. Nee, mache ich nicht. Vielleicht doch. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber das ist wirklich immer so ein Ding, wo man sich der Zuschauer fragt, warum erzählt der das gerade? Warum erzählt der von seinem letzten Urlaub? Und du hast einfach nur die Frage rausgeschnitten. Ja, du kannst als Podcast sagen. Das ist einfach mega unsuper. Maxi Schettenbauer war eigentlich sehr cool, aber wir haben ihn einfach rückblickend haben es geschafft. Alles umgelebt, auch so auf seinem Stand-Up Sachen zusammengeschnitten. Wo wir gerade bei Scheren waren. Ich muss bald wieder zum Friseur und tatsächlich ist es ja das cleverste, wenn du eine bestimmte Frisur willst und bei dir das Problem nicht mit einer lächerlich gut sitzenden Glockenfrisur, aber ich hätte das halt, dass man, bei mir ist alles möglich, ich habe diesen Kopf, den man bekommt als kleines Mädchen, wo man dann so schminken kann, diesen Default-Kopf, wo man auch die Haare schneiden kann und so. So wie beim Rollenspiel, so der, bevor man was geändert hat, so sieht der aus. Ja, genau, so dieser Sims, wo man dann anfangen kann, die Hautfarbe und so einzustellen. Ja, und dann ist es das Cleverste, der wäre es doch eigentlich, mit einem Foto zum Friseur zu gehen und zu sagen, so würde ich gerne aussehen. Aber das ist mir so unangenehm. Und meistens suche ich mir sogar so Fotos raus und google dann so Männerfrisuren und dann suche ich mir so einen Screenshot raus, habe auch so ein paar Screenshots auf meinem Handy und dann sitze ich da beim Friseur und denke mir so, zeigst du jetzt diesen Prominenten, zeige ich jetzt hier. Zeigst du wieder Ryan Gosling. Ich würde gerne so aussehen. Ja, schon mehr Leid, mein Lieber. Ryan Gosling und dann ist es mir so unangenehm. Ja, das kann ich vorstellen. Es ist mir so unangenehm. Aber vor allem, was man das Problem an Frisuren ist ja, dass du dann Hilfe brauchst, wenn du sozusagen, also was ich immer machen möchte, ist, ich denke mir immer, immer wenn mir meine Frisur gefällt, sollte ich ein Foto machen von mir selber, um dann, wenn ich in ein paar Monaten zum Friseur gehe und sage, ich würde gerne genauso aussehen. Aber in dem Moment, in dem du gut aussiehst, denkst du nicht an den Friseur und du denkst nicht daran, dass du jemals wieder scheisse aussehen könntest.
Das ist wieder so die klassische Situation, immer wenn du dieses Foto machen müsstest, hast du am wenigsten Motivation, das Foto zu machen. Das ist ganz toxisch. Wir malen mal einen Graph auf. Momente, in denen man an den Friseur denkt, kurz danach, kurz davor und dann Momente, wo man am wenigsten an den Friseur denkt, wenn die Frisur am besten ist. Und das sind antiproportionale Graphen. Man könnte ja sagen, mach doch einfach ein Foto, nachdem du beim Friseur warst. Nein, denn nachdem du beim Friseur warst, siehst du am beschissensten aus. Weil dann bist du gerade wieder ganz unten. Du musst dann ein paar Tage warten, bis dich so eingegroovt hat, und dann musst du ein Foto machen. Aber dann denkst du dir, oh, sieht doch richtig gut aus. Und dann denkst du, man muss nie wieder zum Friseur. Ich liebe Grafen. Ich liebe Grafen. Ich muss mal bei Twitter mehr Grafen machen. Ja. Von so Lebensproblemen, so die klaren ... Weil Mathematik kann Dinge am besten klar darstellen. Wir haben neulich darüber gesprochen, wie wir Mathematik einfach so gern haben. Und wenn ... man weiß nicht, was die Zukunft bringt. Vielleicht sind wir irgendwann wieder arbeitslos und wir müssten dann mal wieder anfangen, zu studieren oder so. Ich glaube, wir würden beide ... Lassen beide einfach Mathe machen. Eigentlich schon. Weil das ist das klarste, das ist das Gegenteil von Comedy einfach. Weil du hast auch eine klare Antwort. Gibt es so einen VHS-Kurs? Ich habe ja neulich, klingt doof, aber YouTube für mich entdeckt, im Sinne von Vorlesungen angucken. Ja. Weil das ist unglaublich, YouTube ist ja noch so viel vielschichtiger, als ich dachte. Total, und von ganz viele Unis und ganz viele Sachen, auch so TED-Talks und so kennt ja jeder, aber einfach mal durchballern, es gibt unfassbar viel. Vor allem, ich habe neulich einfach so eine MIT-Vorlesung über Mathe angeguckt und habe nichts verstanden. Gar nichts. Und ich dachte mir so, vorher war ich sehr arrogant vor dem Video und dachte mir so, ja gut, ich verstehe das schon, habe meinen Wikipedia-Artikel von dem Thema kurz durchgelesen und dachte mir, ja, ja, gut, so ein paar Basics, die habe ich schon drauf. Und den Rest, learning by doing, okay. Vorlesung angeguckt, nach Minuten 15 dachte ich mir, du hast, du wirst nie in deinem Leben es zu irgendwas bringen. Es ist unfassbar fucking beeindruckend, wie komplex und kompliziert und unverständlich das sein kann. Ich habe mal einen Freund von mir, der hat Physik studiert und den habe ich mal einen Tag lang begleitet in seiner Uni und habe dann so alle Vorlesungen mitbekommen, die er so hat. Und auf Physik, gerade am Anfang hat man auch viel Mathe und dann war da so eine Mathe-Vorlesung über die L'Hôpital, so hieß der Mathematiker, der irgendwie so eine Form von Formeln entdeckt hat, was auch immer. Und ich habe kein einziges Wort verstanden, halt alles nur Buchstaben und Funktionen. Und dann ganz gut, und dann hieß es L'Hôpital irgendwie, ja, und dann habe ich herausgefunden, L'Hôpital hat halt gelebt im 16. Jahrhundert. So da, weil Mathe ist ja nicht an irgendwelche technischen Fortschritte gebunden. Sobald du mal die Leibniz, sobald du mal die Zahlen hast, sobald du mal Newton und Leibniz haben es geschafft, hoch zwei, verstehen wir, Wurzel, past, haben wir alles ab. Dann sind ja alle Möglichkeiten raus. Aber da war auch noch was möglich. Da waren auch noch Dinge unerkannt. Da konntest du noch zu was werden. Auf der anderen Seite, denke ich mir, die sprechen halt auch eine andere Sprache. Das ist halt auch mit diesen ganzen Übersetzungen, den nachsächlichen I, dann A, dann komisches Z-Symbol, was aber eigentlich eine Klammer ist und eigentlich dann oder Matrizen oder sowas. Das sind dann auch alles so verschiedene Sprachen. Wenn du die Sprache gelernt hast erstmal. Ja. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es zu komplex ist, das zu lernen. Ich glaube, nur die Schwelle, um Dinge zu verstehen erstmal, die ist relativ hoch. Ich muss ganz kurz den Typen googeln, damit ich mich jetzt nicht komplett ... El Hospital heißt der Typ.
El Apostroph Hospital.
Ah doch, ja, 17. Jahrhundert. Ja, passt. Kannste rausschneiden.
Ja, wir wissen beide. Ich kenne diesen schnippischen Blick von Stefan T. Passt, kannst du rausschneiden.
Ja, wir wissen beide, ich kenne diesen schnippischen Blick von Stefan T.
Weißt du das? Moment mal.
Die können wir uns zum Brett ums ... Hallo, hallo! He!
Das ist ein Schiff in der Ferne.
Das klingt aber, als wäre es ziemlich weit weg. Hey! Hier in dem Iglu! Hallo! Der Schneesturm ist viel zu dicht, die Flocken zu gross, das Herz zu schwer. SOS! Sie kommen näher! Wo kommt denn hier ein Schiff her? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass wir so nah am Meer sind.
Unsere Eischoll ist weggetrieben. Ruder, schnell, Ruder in die Richtung!
Oh, ein Otter, äh, also wie sind, wie heißen die, Seehund. Wir halten uns am Seehund fest, Sie Igel. Zieh uns, kleiner Freund. Und so waren sie gerettet. So ging das dann. Die Podcast-Eisscholle. Sie nervt immer mal aus. Ja, immer mal aus, echt nervig, doofe Idee. Aber das ist die neue ... Ich finde es ... War jetzt die ganze Zeit die Klimaanlage an? Ist das schein egal. Willst du mich ver... Lass die doch mal an. Stefan T-Punkt, ey, das kann nicht sein. Ist doch völlig egal, die Klimaanlage. Nein, ich lass die jetzt an. Die Leute denken, wir haben den Scheiß extra reingeschnitten, um davon abzulenken, dass die Klimaanlage die ganze Zeit anfängt. Nein, wir haben das reingeschnitten, weil wir keine Themen haben, weil wir uns nichts überlegt haben. Und das ist jetzt der neue Trick. Der neue Trick ist jetzt, wenn wir uns nichts erlebt haben die Woche, wenn wir beide nur auf unserem faulen Arsch sitzen und Netflix gucken, dann machen wir einfach das. Dann machen wir jetzt Sound-Episoden. Du hast heute mal erzählt, dass du deine 100 Lieblingsfilme zusammengetragen hast. Hast du Interesse daran, diese Liste zu veröffentlichen? Ich glaube, da werden viele Leute interessiert. Die 100 Top-Filme von Stefan T. Ja, aber das waren die 100 Top-Filme im Februar 2012. Da hatte ich einen sehr speziellen Geschmack. Da hatte ich diese Emo-Phase. Ja, viel alte französische, hier Jean-La-Blabla-Place, Filini, François-Cellin. Ja, aber ich hätte Bock darauf. Also wir sollten das beide machen. Und zwar sollten wir beide die Top-100 machen. Das überschneidet sich so stark einfach, dass wenn's ja ... Du kennst ja auch nicht die, die dann den Top-1000-Filme machen, das überschneidet sich dann, da sind ja die gleichen Filme drin. Nee, aber interessant ist ja, dass man es mal in so einem Gespräch zwischendurch einfließen lassen kann. So, übrigens mal 99, König der Löwen. Stimmt. Platz zwei Smurfs. Oh, Smurfs zwei. Smurfs zwei war richtig gut. Smurfs zwei. Nee, ich dachte mir schon oft, weil ich krieg manchmal so Nachrichten so, hey, was sind deine Lieblingsfilme, kannst du irgendwas empfehlen, Serien und so, ob man nicht irgendwo, das hatte ich schon mal erzählt, glaube ich, dass man irgendwo. Du kannst ja bei IMDb, das ist ja auch noch eine Seite mit unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten. Stimmt, wir haben heute YouTube entdeckt, jetzt entdecken wir mal IMDb. Ja, du kannst natürlich da alle Filme, die du jemals geguckt hast, werten und der legt auch nochmal eine Datenbank an mit allen Filmen, die du gesehen hast, allen Filmen, die du bewertet hast. Mega geil. Ja, aber da habe ich bis jetzt schon mindestens 20 Filme, denen ich 10 Sterne gegeben habe. Ja, aber theoretisch kannst du da auch noch so Listen anfertigen. Und da kannst du auch zu jedem Film noch ein bisschen was schreiben. Da kann man bei Flo und Tee Will draufklicken. Stimmt, so eine Liste. Und dann kann man die veröffentlichen. Wieso okay. Und auch mit Serien. Ja, das ist natürlich richtig cool. Ah, das ist natürlich cool. Und da kannst du auch immer kleine Texte zu schreiben, so. Wer darauf steht, muss sich das angucken. Wer dem Blut nicht gefällt und auch nicht lachen möchte, für den ist die Serie leider nichts. Kein Scream für dich. Ja, aber das ist glaube ich nicht schlecht. Könnte ich vielleicht mal machen. Mach mal. Also ich wurde auch neulich gefragt, als ich was zu Dunkirk geschrieben habe, an Ulk, wie mir der Film gefiel und so. Und ich wollte erst was schreiben, aber irgendwie habe ich auch nicht Twitter dann als die beste Plattform dafür empfunden, weil so 140 Zeichen, Leute schreiben dann immer schnell, wow, der Film hat mir aber gar nicht gefallen und dann haben sie noch für 60 Zeichen Platz, ohne Begründung zu finden. Das ist immer so ein bisschen blöd und wird dem Film auch nicht gerecht, wo man sich zweieinhalb Stunden reingesetzt hat, um den zu gucken. Ich denke mir oft immer, dass ich mit meiner Meinung mehr Schaden anrichten kann als helfen, weil ich denke mir so, eigentlich sollte es dir egal sein, was ich denke, wer bin ich denn?
Also ich bin, wenn du jetzt einen Filmkritiker fragst, ja, wenn du jemanden, keine Ahnung, Tarantino fragst, hey, wie fandest du Dunkirk, dann kommt da bestimmt eine interessante Antwort, aber ich, also ich kann verstehen, dass wenn Leute verfolgen, was ich mache und mich als Bezugsperson akzeptieren, dann wissen wollen, was ich schaue, aber ich denke immer so, mein Geschmack hilft euch nicht, so, weil ich habe keine Ahnung davon, was ich tue jetzt, wirklich jemand, der krass Ahnung hat und alles, weil ich sehe vielleicht von allen Filmen 0,1%. Naja, aber du bist doch Schauspieler, also, weil ich nicht als Schauspieler war, weil ich mich als Autor wahrnehme. Es gibt ja oft die Sache, dass man sagt, okay, Film A ist gut, aber man findet Film A nur gut, weil man Film B, C, D und E nicht gesehen hat, weil die viel besser sind. Und weißt du, du brauchst auch einen gewissen Hintergrundwesen. Dann freuen sich die Filme doch wenigstens, dann freuen sich die Leute zumindest über die Tipps, die vierte Filmtipps. Die ich aber nicht gesehen habe. Ich bin so arrogant zu behaupten, dass meine Kritik interessant sein kann. Okay. Worauf basierst du das? Warum denkst du, dass deine Kritik interessant ist? Leute hören uns ja auch, weil wir unterhaltsam sind. Filmkritik ist ja auch nichts anderes als eine andere Form der Unterhaltung. Aber Unterhaltung ist das Gegenteil von Kompetenz. Nee, das stimmt überhaupt. Das ist volliger Bullshit. Jetzt hast du uns gerade, Alter, du hast uns gerade jegliche Kompetenz abgesprochen. Oder jegliche Unterhaltung. Ja, oder das, weil es furchtbar, man weiß nicht, was schlimmer ist. Also, erst mal bin ich Autor, hauptberuflich, du bist hauptberuflich Schauspieler, heisst unsere Jobs haben schon mal so eine gewisse Berechtigung, was zu filmen zu sagen. Jetzt im Speziellen. Oder gerade nicht, weil wir gerade selber total tief drinstecken und immer subjektiv. Bäcker sollten dir nicht sagen, was können sie heute empfehlen, ey, ich steck zu tief drin. Ich hab heute Morgen diese Laugröschung gemacht, ich habe gerade eben diesen Streuselgucken gemacht, ich habe keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist es bei Streuselgucken was anderes. Aber ich würde schon sagen, ich würde nicht, naja, weiß ich nicht, einerseits eine fundierte Kritik kriegst du natürlich von so Leuten nicht, weil die halt total drinstecken und weil die ja selber eine Vision haben, wie sollte ein Film sein. So, ich würde uns jedenfalls eine gewisse Unterhaltsamkeit unterstellen und eine gewisse Expertise auf dem Gebiet. Also, glaube ich, sind wir relativ gut geeignet dafür als Ansprechpartner für Filmkritik. Ich glaube, dass gerade bei solchen Sachen so der Beruf des Kritikers schon wichtig ist, der nicht selber involviert ist und der halt ein breites Feld an Meinungen hat. Wohingegen, wir haben zum Beispiel eine gewisse Vorstellung, wie Comedy sein soll. Wir haben einfach gewisse Sachen, die mögen wir nicht und wir wissen, Comedy soll so sein. Comedy-Filme finde ich tatsächlich das interessant, das ist aber auch noch ein bisschen was anderes. Aber ich glaube, da sind wir wirklich keine guten Ansprechpartner, weil wir die meisten Sachen einfach nicht gut finden werden. Oder halt Sachen gut finden, wo wir halt irgendwie eine Vorstellung haben. Also ich glaube, für Filme generell verstehe ich, warum Leute dich fragen. Und ich habe auch immer überlegt, um so so einen Podcast zu machen oder so, oder so ein kleines Format für Mädchen. Lass uns mal einen schönen Filmpodcast machen. Mal mal ein bisschen was man über Filme sagt. Der Filmtalk. Wir machen mal einen schönen Filmtalk. Ey, Filme aufs Ohr. Oder wir gucken mal so einen Film. Und dann machen wir einen Audiokommentar dazu und dann können die Leute sich den anhören. Zu einem Film, den die Community sich aussucht für uns. Und dann natürlich, wie ich die Community kenne, wird es dann irgendwie Sex in the City 2 sein, Smurfs, fucking Smurfs. Ich bin mittlerweile auch echt in so einem Unterhaltungslimbo gefangen, dass ich nicht mehr weiß, was ich anschauen soll. Ich switche immer zwischen Serien, einzelnen Serien und dann zwischen Serien und Filmen, dann wieder Filmen und irgendwas anderem. Ich bin mittlerweile so überfordert mit dem Überangebot an Dingen. Ich habe gestern zwei Filme angefangen. Einmal den Film Habermann über irgendwie so Nazi in der Nachkriegszeit irgendwie hier. Über Jürgen Habermann. An dem sie die Rechte nicht bekommen haben. Also, Jochen Habermann, ein berühmter Kommunikationswesen So ein Film mit Ben Becker unter anderem, dachte ich mir, ah cooler Film, aber das ist dann einer, leider sind bei diesen historischen und gerade in den Nazifilmen sind es immer so dusselige Koproduktionen zwischen tschechischem und deutschen und die sind leider oft so schlecht geschrieben, dass es so unerträglich ist und die haben kein Gefühl für Spannung oder Figuren, das ist alles schlecht, obwohl mich das Sujet interessieren würde. Dann habe ich angeschaut auf Netflix Defiance mit Daniel Craig, irgendwie so polnische Partisanen, auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg, habe ich auch angeschaut, auch aufgehört nach zehn Minuten. So, und dann sitzt du da und denkst dir, und dann liegst du im Bett und denkst dir, da hätte ich auch einfach nichts machen können. Das habe ich auch früher noch nie gemacht. Ich habe früher niemals Filme aufgehört zu gucken. Das ist gut. Das sollte man machen. Das ist auch mittlerweile irgendwie bei mir auch Zugewohnheit so, dass ich mal Serien anfange und nicht zu Ende gucke. Auch Ozark habe ich erst so die erste Folge geguckt, fand es ganz cool, dann die zweite, dritte und dann irgendwann auch aufgehört. Wobei ich es bei Serien noch verstehe, weil du da auch ein Commitment einge, in sehr viel Zeit, deines Lebens zu opfern, aber ich höre auch auf Filme zu gucken so und das ist auch, mittlerweile bin ich auch abends sitze ich schwitzend vom Fernseher und denke mir so, fuck, was gucke ich jetzt, was mache ich jetzt, ich könnte eine neue Folge Rick and Morty gucken, ich könnte endlich mal mit der neuen Staffel Game of Thrones anfangen, ich habe aber auch gerade Bock auf Doctor House, dann habe ich 50 Filme auf der Watchlist bei Netflix, 120 Filme auf der Watchlist bei iTunes. So, was gucke ich jetzt? Und ich bin bestimmt eine Stunde am überlegen, was ich gucke, dann noch eine Stunde am überlegen, dabei Dinge anzufangen und dann aufzuhören, bis ich mich mal irgendwann entschieden habe. Weil die Opportunitätskosten zu gross mittlerweile sind. Weil du an zu viel kommst. Es wird auch immer schlimmer. Ich denke mir, mit jedem solcher Abende fünf Sachen angefangen, denke ich mir, es wird schlimmer. Meine Aufmerksamkeitsspanne ist an diesem heutigen Abend noch ein bisschen geschrumpft. Morgen wird's noch schlimmer. Ja, ich denke mir vor allem mittlerweile, ich habe gerade nicht diesen neuen Film geguckt. Ich habe stattdessen hunderttausend andere Filme nicht geguckt. So denk ich mittlerweile. Ich habe hunderttausend Filme heute Abend nicht gesehen, weil ich diesen einen Film geguckt habe. Ist ne harte Zeit, ey, man muss das auch wieder mal wieder, man muss das trainieren und lernen, Aufmerksamkeit sparen. Oder mal so fünf Jahre lang Leuten verbieten, Dinge rauszubringen. So, ab jetzt haben wir fünf Jahre Zeit. Die Aufhol-Etappe.
Die Weltwirtschaft bricht zusammen.
Spart mal lieber, und dann spart euch die Billigproduktion, macht dann geile Filme.
Fang jetzt an zu schreiben, um in fünf Jahren eine bessere Staffel Game of Thrones zu schreiben.
Und jetzt macht mal fünf Jahre lang nichts.
Bringt mal nichts raus, so ein Verbot, was rauszubringen.
Ja, da gibt es bestimmt irgendwie so einen Frechdachs, der auf YouTube dann doch wieder weiter Videos macht.
Ja, ich weiß, der scheiss Rebell! Dann gehen alle zu dem und sagen, ah geil, ich hol mir die Klicks vom Klickbaum. Ich glaube, 17.52 hatte der September nur 20 Tage, weil Leute gemerkt haben, unsere Zeitrechnung funktioniert nicht, wir killen 10 Tage. Und seitdem, da hatten Leute auch da Geburtstag, so und dann ... Ich glaub, bei Franklin oder so, da stehen jetzt zwei Jahre total als Geburtstag. Entweder am 22. Februar oder am 10. Februar das Jahr davor Geburtstag. Irgendwie so ein Bullshit. Weil die da in seinem Jahr einfach zehn Tage getötet haben, damit die Sonne wieder einigermaßen hinkommt. Das ist ja ultra verwirrend. Mega verwirrend, auch jetzt rückblickend mega verwirrend, weil man nicht genau weiß, war damals der 24. Dezember der 24. Dezember, den wir heute haben und so weiter, weiß man gar nicht mehr.
Kommt alles verloren.
Weißt du, ein Land, ein paar Leute in einem Land haben das entschieden und die gesamte Menschheit leidet darunter für den Rest der Zeit, weil du immer denkst, oh Sonnenfinstern, vor zehn Millionen Jahren, am vierten Moment, war das da der achte, sechste, siebte, ach Gott. Das will ich auch Anna Frebel fragen. Schick uns noch weitere Fragen, wir haben schon ein paar bekommen. Es wird immer konkreter. Star-Astronome, die bald zu uns kommen. Wortwörtlich Star-Astronome. Wow! Und wir sind nur, was ist denn ihr Lieblingsmusical? Okay! Star-Line! Wer ist denn ihr Lieblings-Star-Star? Ja, und genau, da habe ich mir auch überlegt, sowas zu fragen wie, warum man sich nicht einfach als Mensch irgendwann sagt, fuck it Tage, fuck it Sekunden, sondern einfach sich anfängt an Naturkonstanten zu gewöhnen. Und wenn die Sonne in diesem Zeitpunkt des Jahres dasteht, ist dieser Zeitpunkt des Jahres und nicht der 24. Februar, weil wir uns das mal irgendwann ausgedacht haben. Ja, aber gut, dann hast du irgendwann zwölf Uhr und es ist dunkel. Nee, nee, einfach nach der Sonne. Zwölf Uhr mittags und es ist schockdunkel. Du musst es ja immer anpassen, damit so die Gewohnheiten des Menschen übereinstimmen. Ja, aber nun mal, es ist es nun mal so, dass wir nicht dreimal 65 Tage um die Sonne brauchen, sondern halt ein bisschen schneller sind.
Ja, aber das ist ja noch verwirrender, wenn du dann in dem Buch liest und ich stand auf um 16.30 Uhr, weißt du nicht, ja ist das jetzt früh oder spät, weil für mich ist es spät, aber die Sonne. Wir brauchen 23,9 Stunden. Ja, das verstehe ich schon, aber du musst es ja trotzdem anpassen, damit es gleich ist. Ja, deswegen brauchen wir andere Einer für Sekunde, andere Einer für Minuten. Ach so. Achso, und dann hast du einfach, jetzt ist der Tag halt, unsere neun, vierundzwanzig Stunden sind halt eigentlich dreiundzwanzig, neun Stunden. Und deswegen passt das dann besser so. Warum man als Mensch diese Arroganz hat, Einheiten zu kreieren. Mich würde interessieren, ob man in der Wissenschaft auch mit unserem Datum rechnet, oder ob man nicht einfach sagt, okay, Tag null, Tag eins, heute ist halt Tag 26.436, damit man nicht immer diesen März und September und dann ist das jetzt ein Schaltjahr und 31.30. Mega bescheuert. Dumme Scheisse da. Frundi, hey. Kein Bock mehr, er ist gar kein Bock mehr einfach. Du hast da mich so eine Wutkrankheit. Ja, dann bring doch deinen Sozi-Scheiss hier über uns alle, ey. Diese linksverzifftige Katze. Wenn erst mal die roten Flaggen wehen, ja, dann haben wir eine ganz andere Gesellschaft. Die Welt unter hat doch noch nicht funktioniert damals. Das war Amanteure. Ich könnte das besser. Okay, was machen wir mit unserem Inuit-Volk, was wir jetzt aber mit unseren Frachter hier bekommen haben? Was machen wir mit denen? Die kriegen Geld vom Staat, so viel sie wollen. So, gut, dann haben wir jetzt kein Geld mehr. Ja, gut, ohne Geld... Staatskasten sind leer. Wie willst du die Wirtschaft ankurbeln? Die machen doch nichts damit. Die sitzen da auf ihrem Scheiss Inuit, Verzeihung, Eskimo-Hintern, sitzen die da und machen nichts. Die arbeiten noch nicht. Da kommt kein Konkurrenzverhalten auf oder so, die sterben doch alle, weil die jetzt alle zufrieden sind. Gesättigt in ihrem Scheiss Fisch.
Es war ein Fehler, unser ganzes Geld in Inno hier zu geben, da zähle ich jetzt auch ein. Sorry, Entschuldigung, aber ab jetzt gibt's kein Geld mehr, wir haben jetzt nur noch Lebenszeit und jeder muss selber überlegen, was er damit macht. Ich dachte, jeder kriegt so ein bisschen Geld.
Wer Brot will, der kommt zum Brotmann und kriegt Brot.
Jeder kriegt so ein paar bisschen Geld, aber die, die arbeiten, die kriegen richtig Geld. So, und auf alles Geld, was sie haben, geben wir denen so ein bisschen, nehmen wir denen so ein bisschen Geld ab. Ja, aber das ist ungleich verteilt mit Privilegien und so ein Scheiß. Die, die mehr machen, kriegen auch mehr. Ich wollte gar nicht Bundeskanzler sein. Ich wollte das nicht. Du bist Eiskönig, Eiskanzler. Leute, ja was, wieder so eine Pressekonferenz, ey, nervt doch nicht. Scheiss, Eski-Bose. Angel Meckler wurde bei einer Pressekonferenz gefragt, warum sie nur einmal im Jahr zu Pressekonferenzen kommt. Und die richtige Antwort ist, ja, weil ich keinen fucking scheiss Bock hab auf ihr Deppen, weil ihr alles hinterfragt, was ich mache. Aber jeder weiß, dass das die richtige Antwort ist. Aber sie sagt halt, nein, das ergibt sich nicht so oft und ach, stimmt doch gar nicht, bin doch ganz gut. Warum muss denn der amerikanische Präsident so häufig vor die Presse? Das ist nicht auch ein bisschen offengelebtere Demokratie? Ich weiß es nicht, aber jeder weiß, was die Antwort ist, zu sagen einfach, ja, ich habe keinen Bock, mich mit euch Trotteln rumzuschlagen. Ach sie das nicht? Ach, da gibt ja tausend Pressekonferenzen das ganze Jahr.
Ne, so viel nicht, wo man wirklich so für die frei so Fragen stellen kann.
Ach so, freien Fragen stellen kann.
Ja, wenn die einfach nur einen Text vorliest, klar, aber so wirklich, wo man Fragen stellen kann.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch bessere amerikanische Serien, das fühlt sich auch alles besser an, weil es einfach cooler ist. Das Wahlsystem ist cooler.
House of Cards will die nicht mehr zu nehmen.
Ey, das fucking Gerichtssystem ist hundertmal so cool.
Ja, aber auch diese Pressekonferenzen, die die da immer haben, wo der Pressesprecher vor die Fresse tritt und so, dieser Raum und so, und dass die auch alle mit Vornamen kennen, das ist einfach alles cooler, es sieht doch cooler aus mit diesem Pult. Ja, das stimmt schon. Wo ich auf hinaus wollte, warum wurde es eigentlich irgendwann so ein brisantes Thema, dass man nicht mehr Eskimo sagen durfte, dann wurde man öffentlich angefeindet und mittlerweile sagen alle noch Inuit. Wer hat sich da mal darüber beschwert? Hast du jemals ein Eskimo getroffen? Warum interessiert das die überhaupt? Die kriegen das noch nicht mit. Wer wird es denn beleidigt? Das ist ja auch, in welcher Sprache ist das denn so? Kennen die denn das Wort Eskimo? Ich meine, die haben doch nichts mit uns Europäern zu tun, selbst, also die sind noch ganz Indianer-Ding. Man soll sich nicht Eskimos nennen, weil das unsere scheiß weiße alte Männer-Wort war, was wir erfunden haben. Mit wir meine ich die alten weißen Herren vor uns. Und man soll das deshalb nicht nennen, weil die sich selber Inuit nennen. Ja, aber die sprechen ja eine andere Sprache als wir. Man soll Aborigines auch nicht voll dessen nennen. Chinesen heißen ja in China auch nicht Chinesen, sondern halt dann das chinesische Wort für Chinesen. Wichser. Leider das chinesische Wort. Nicht unsere Entscheidung, ihre. Also das ist ja, ich verstehe es nicht, ich stecke nicht drin, da gibt es bestimmt irgendwie total tolle Sachen. Das ist auch unser Problem, wir wissen zu wenig. Wir haben keine Ahnung von nichts. Deswegen bin ich sehr gespannt, wie wir Anna Frebel aufnehmen, die einfach mit ihrer geballten Kompetenz hier reinsteuert und alles weiß. Ja, die wird mit dem grossen Gehirn gar nicht durch unsere kleinen Türchen gekommen. Stimmt. Metaphorisch passt die gar nicht durch unseren begrenzten Rahmen durch. Ich würde gerne mal in so ein Schlaflabor oder so ein ...
Beruflich schlafen, ne?
Da messen die ja auch so die Gehirnwellen und so.
Ich will mal wissen, was ist denn jetzt so Stand? Was ist denn so Status quo? Was ist so der Status quo? Seid mal ehrlich, seid mal echt ehrlich jetzt. Sag mal jetzt und dann bricht so ein Roast von Stefan Dieter aus. Ja, Alpha-Vane so gut wie keine. Oh, Beta-Vane, ein bisschen was ist noch da. Gam Oh, Gamma-Vane, viel zu hoch! Oder, je nachdem. War es ein billiges Schlaflabor? Ist es ein Wohnwagen mit einer Mikrowelle? Es ist ein Van mit verdunkelten Scheiben. Das ist das Problem. Van. Ich war neulich beim Arzt und dann bin ich da hingegangen, dann kam ich auch relativ schnell dran, das war wegen meines Busselportunfalls, und dann bin ich ins Wartezimmer gekommen. Stefan Tietze in den Auslachraum, Stefan Tietze in den Auslachraum. Ähnlich, Stefan Tietze ins Wartezimmer bitte, dann kam ich sofort dran und dann bin ich auf, dann hat man seinen Namen, Tietze bitte, Tietze bitte, und dann höre ich erst nicht ich erst nicht hin. Weißt du, da kenn ich nichts, sie sprechen meinen Namen falsch aus, da hör ich auch nicht hin. Ich bin weiter in die Brigitte vertieft. Dann Tietze! Dann stehe ich auf. Haha! Tietzling! Dann bin ich aufgestanden zu ihr, und dann hat sie das Erste, was sie gesagt hat, war, ja, wir gehen jetzt in den Keller. Und das willst du nicht hören beim Arzt. Du willst den Satz, ja, wir gehen heute mal in den Keller, willst du nicht hören. Du willst dich im Keller, Keller ist unhygienisch, nichts im Keller macht mich gesund. Mit jeder Stufe steigen, sinken deine Überlebenschancen. Mit jeder Stufe wird mein Herzschlag ein bisschen langsamer. Und dann war unten auch noch so ein Besprechungsraum, aber auch da, da kommt halt auch kein Licht rein, heisst es ist verdunkelt, die Neonröhren flackern, das ist doch kein Arzt. Das ist doch kein Arzt. Betreiben Sie Sport? Ja, verdammt nochmal, Sie treiben keinen Sport! Okay, okay, ich gestehe. Ich sehe es an Ihren Werten, wenn überhaupt mal einmal die Woche auf dem Heimtrainer, oder? Ich gestehe, ich habe noch nie Sport gemacht. Manchmal war ich auf dem Stepper. Da haben wir es doch! Ich bin einmal in der Woche auf dem Stepper.
Stepper.
Was ist das für ein Wort.
Aber ging's dann gut, geht's dir besser mittlerweile mit einer Verwundung.
Ja, es verheilt die Wunde und dann manchmal werden die Strassen unsicher, würde ich sagen.
Biu-Biu!
Wurde das jetzt als Verletzung oder als Verwundung bezeichnet? Ich glaube, Verwundung ist schon mal ernster. Ich glaube, das Wort existiert nicht. Verwundung ist eine Schürfwunde, von daher passt der Wortstamm schon mal ein bisschen besser. Aber es ist eine Schürfwunde, die hat die obersten Hautschichten weggeflext, hat er gesagt. Und wir machen erst ein Pflaster drauf und dann ist Jut.
Man kann nichts an den Menschen kleben, ne? Doch, Pflaster. Selbst der beste Kleber der Welt. Und du kannst nicht was an die Haut kleben, weil die Haut kann sich ablösen, wenn sie will. Wenn sie will. Und die Haut kann auch aus sich selbst Feuchtigkeit rausdrücken, mit der man den Kleber wegdrücken kann. Ich habe ja mal den schlimmsten Sonnenbrand aller Zeiten bekommen im Urlaub.
Und ich glaube mittlerweile, ich habe auf jeden Fall Hautkrebs, also da mache ich mir auch keine Hoffnung mehr irgendwie. Und dann der Kumpel, mit dem ich dann da war, der das gleiche Problem hatte, der sich auch komplett, wir haben uns dann gleichzeitig den Urlaub verkackt und haben uns dann gepellt während des Urlaubs so und wir waren dann am ersten Tag in der Apotheke und der Apotheker hat gesagt, sie sollten nicht mehr in die Sonne gehen. Ein Satz, den man am ersten Tag im Urlaub auf jeden Fall nicht zu hören will. Und dieser besagte Kumpel ist jetzt im Urlaub und meinte, er wird auch nicht mehr braun am Oberkörper, sondern er bildet sich nur noch so Sommerspräuzen gefährliche. Und bei mir ist es ähnlich. Ich glaube, wir haben beide einfach ja unser Todesunterhalt damals unterschrieben. Können wir nicht in ein anderes Sonnensystem gehen?
Mit einem blauen Stern oder so, immer dieses fucking gelb und weiss?
Und irgendwann wird es zum roten Riesen.
Die Sonne wird zum roten Riesen, wenn die Supernova kommt.
Frau Frebel, wie lange dauert es bis zum roten Riesen, fragt das Podcast-UFO.
Noch 16 Millionen Jahre. Dann haben wir wir noch mehr Zeit, jetzt zum Sport. Es war eine komische Folge, wir waren ein bisschen komisch. Wir sind in Danzig eingefallen, der rote Sturm wird sie hinwegfegen. Man sollte ja denken, dass man bei, also wenn man Vergangenheitsradio hört, also Radio in der Vergangenheit, da denkt man ja eigentlich, okay, die Mikrofone waren noch nicht so gut, wahrscheinlich reden alle ein bisschen leiser. Tatsächlich ist alles ein bisschen lauter, es ist immer noch ein bisschen übersteuert und heute sind die Kapitalisten vorgedrungen. Und vor allem, ich habe neulich viele Dokus über die Nürnberger Brustländer geguckt. Ah, geil. Geil, einfach geil, diese Leute zu sehen, wie sie mit der Wahl konfrontiert werden. Oh, es ist toll, und Hermann Göring.
Oh, Göring.
Die sprechen einfach anders.
Ja.
Vor allem, das sind teilweise ganz die originalen Tonaufnahmen hören.
Und es ist das Beste der Welt, weil die reden auch einfach anders.
Und die reden auch einfach gestochen per...
Und die haben kein Äs, die sagen nichts wie Ä.
Nichts.
Das wird ihnen ausgepeitscht in der Jugendschaft.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, woher das kommt.
Auch die Richter und so, Dolmetscher, niemand hat ein Äh gesagt. Das ist einfach nicht existent zu der Zeit. Die reden auch langsamer, also die Uhren tickten auch damals wahrscheinlich ein bisschen langsamer, und die haben einfach so eine ganz klare, präzise Ausdrucksweise. Die denken nicht immer weiter nach, aber die sprechen einfach langsamer. Hitler ist zu uns ins Büro gekommen und hat uns die Befehle gegeben. Daraufhin haben wir sie ausgeführt. Das ist nicht schlecht. So reden! Ey, wenn das nun keine perfekte Hermann-Göring-Imitation von Stefan T. Itzel war, dann bin ich mir aber auch nicht sicher. Und ganz kurz, würdest du gerne mal verhört werden als Angeklagter? Ich habe ja mal selber jemanden angeklagt, als ich damals verprügelt wurde. Der Karate-Meister. Als der Freestyle-Karate-Meister mich verprügelt hat. Was klingt rückblickend, ohne Kontext, als ob ich einfach auf der Straße vom Ninja angeklagt. Von so einem Ninja-Turtle, ja. Und dann habe ich den ja angeklagt. Dann kam das tatsächlich tatsächlich auch ... Weil dann stellte die halt auch Fragen. Haben Sie was getrunken an dem Abend? Sie haben gesagt, Sie kamen von der Party. Äh, ich ... ja gut, ich kam halt ... Aber ich hab nichts ... Weitenscheule, weitenscheule! Dose Bier, gibt's Hosen noch, weiß ich nicht! Du bist halt so wahnsinnig aufgeregt, weil du kommst ja jetzt selber vor. Und da hab ich mich auch teilweise so gefühlt, als ob ich verhört wurde. Da war ich ja auch beim Gericht und habe mich dann selber verteidigt.
Und das war auch so crazy. Und du kommst dir halt schon vor, weil dir halt so Fragen gestellt werden. Die haben ja auch krasse Methoden, wie dir dann so gegenchecken und nochmal nachfragen und dann ganz am Ende nochmal mit einer anderen Fragestellung die Frage von Anfang anstellen. Das macht einen schon ein bisschen mürbe. Das ist schon nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, ich möchte auch nicht sterben, bevor ich nicht einmal im grossen Saal mich so ein ganz dünnes, langes Stielmikrofon nach vorne gelehnt habe und gesagt habe. Kein Kommentar. Daran kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Dann kann ich sterben. Wenn ich das einmal gesagt hätte, dieses nach vorne lehnen. Ich meine, man kann auch die Mikrofone länger machen, die sind ja schon recht lang, aber nein, die sind so kurz. Wahrscheinlich muss man sich gar nicht nach vorne, aber jeder denkt, man muss sich... Aber auch immer das so einatmen, du musst erst mal so einatmen. Danke, bitte. Ich kann mich an den Abend nicht erinnern. Und dann auch so verheissungsvoll nach zurücklehnen und weggucken, leer in den Raum gucken. Alter, ey. Und dann so eine Dokustimme. Auch Florentin will sich an diesen Abend wirklich nicht erinnern, konnte es bis heute umgeklärt, nach seinem Suizid am nächsten Tag. Der Mandant schweigt. Also ich. Es ist aber auch, dann hat sich Göring ja nach dem Urteil selbst umgebracht mit der Zyankali-Kapsel und dieser Wichser hatte dann auch noch so eine Notiz hinterlegt. Seine Sterbennotiz war ja, haha, ich hätte sogar noch eine andere gehabt, die ihr da und da findet. Und da, wo er dann geschrieben hat, wo es die gibt, war wirklich doch eine Zyankalikaste. Als er hatte noch mehrere, die ihm zugesteckt wurden. Haha, in your face! Und seine letzte Notiz war, ich habe sogar noch eine andere gehabt, und da war sie. Das ist schon gut. War es ein Wichser, er ist als Wichser gestorben auch einfach. Also er ist wirklich... Ich klam dich dann an alles, was du noch hast, ne, wenn du so ein wahnsinnig mächtiger, so der zweite Mann im deutschen Reich so mächtig bist und plötzlich hier sitzt du in der Gefängniszelle, du bist es ja, du kannst ja den Machtdurst nicht einfach ablegen, den du gelebt hast jahrelang. Du musst dann schon irgendwas so, ich muss mich über andere erheben und irgendwie der Krasse sein und am Ende habe ich noch ein Stückchen. Und wenn es so die Zio-Karrikapsel ist, die er in dem Kerzenständer versteckt hat. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Schon geil. Schon verrückt. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber vielen Dank, ich glaube, dank deiner Göring-Imitation sind jetzt viele Leute wieder wach, die eingeschlafen
sind und die jetzt komplett genervt und erbostig noch den Rest dieser Frage. Nee, komplett mit
aufgerissenen Augen, verängstigt im Bett liegen. Bis zum nächsten Mal, wenn es wieder heisst,
der Podcast-UFO. Das Podcast hebt ab. Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh,
ciao, buh, buh, buh, buh. Das Podcast hebt ab.ご視聴ありがとうございました。